it is no delusion that you are on a hike
with your girlfriends and you came
across a bear is in real life like
in real true life we went on a hike we
went to these mountains so you're
walking in the woods yeah and you're
hiking and you're talking what happens
act it out with me okay uh so like i'm
walking and my am i casually well no
we're not walking like
we're walking like this oh my god oh my
god oh my god and then i'm walking and
you're the bear and okay so we see a
bear walking now here's the thing
there's a brown bear and a black bear
and there's two different ways to react
and i didn't know i couldn't remember
which was which do we go
and scare the bear or do you do this and
i forgot which was which so i did both
so i kept going like
well the bear took one look at us and
was like i'm so not interested in
youtube people and kev and kept going
but it is the scariest thing in the
world it's like what i imagine swimming
with sharks to actually be
this close to an animal in the wild it's
really so terrifying so i heard you're a
clamor thank you yes i am so that feels
very proud i love clams i love clams
tell me about clams okay it's so
meditative to clam you you use a clam
fork a rake and you you know you dig and
you dig and then you're rewarded you
find these little gems and
i need a clamming partner so i brought a
gift for you wait really yes oh
oh god thank you
okay
and
the wait
okay
um
so ally will you tell everybody about
your book really quickly yes goodbye
tell them why they should read it okay
let's just focus on me hi
welcome to allie wentworth in the alley
show
so the great thing about clamming is
that you dig into the sand with your
hands or your rake and you pull up these
little jewels
and
um that's why i love clamming
and
i actually need a partner
there we go
by the way trust the gordon's fisherman
no kidding thank you for that
[Applause]
we're going to do a short film about us
clamming um
and i have a present for you because the
last time we surprised mariska it was a
birthday cake yeah and we wanted to feel
um we wanted you to feel good and funny
enough on the cover of your book you're
eating none other than the fudgy the
whale cake so go carve out
that cake
oh thank you cat oh my god
i'm in the right outfit so that i can
just motorboat this cake
by the way how great is this with the
crunch it's so good it's so good i
noticed it on the cover of your book and
i was like oh my god we gave him a risk
of this cake so we gotta get one for
ally and more importantly i'm so excited
to tell everybody
that not only are you guys going home
with a copy of ally's book but a 50 gift
card to carvel
because everybody
needs a little alley and a little fudgie
ellie went where's ellie's book all
allies well
that ends well and my tongue is so twi
see ellie take it away tell everybody
about it okay my book ally's well that
ends well is available now wherever
books are sold
[Music]